[Music]
i love you
santa you have no life outside of your
kids well my wife is an architect we've
made a decision that's best for me to
take care of the kids it's called a
system which works
yeah prison system that's what it sounds
like
my birthday's coming up you haven't been
to one of my parties forever you guys
were so close and then i grew up i don't
want to spend a weekend with huck and a
bunch of 22 year olds
i have an idea i should take dash and
ava for spring break by myself you've
never traveled with them without me i am
their mother i will be fine honestly i
have concerns did you hear me no dash
get your stuff
let's go
every parent's dream is to spend a week
without their family i get some meat
meat how was your first day of freedom
it was great i played golf with some old
buddies of mine
i went to this underground barbecue spot
you're good bro yeah i'm all right
you should go to hawk's party baby happy
birthday thank you brother you look good
hey whoa hey guys say hi to my oldest
friend of the world yeah you want a
towel no i'm good okay
this week isn't about me it's about us
okay in the majestic california
it's our own burning man we're in the
middle of nowhere where the poor party's
at right there
that's a bucket yeah they were great
everybody over here a party over there
buddy aren't you a little scary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just got back together
oh my god way to make the most of your
me time huh
i don't know what happened but you're a
new man i've done a lot of stuff i'm not
proud of you
oh my god like it looks like a hot
cheeto don't touch it what is going on
it's hot he's always got me doing stupid
[ __ ] we gotta do this together it's
always something crazy i just feel like
this is too much i'll see you later
[Applause]
open your arms like a starfish glasses
came back
i told you you could do it i love you
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
you